vous me faites un grand honneur de me
choisir pour une deuxième fois comme
votre premier ministre l'impôt sur les
grandes fortunes ça s'applique après un
million d'actifs
ce soir
nous ne sommes plus revenus pour revenir
nous sommes arrivés à ce qui commence
[Musique]
nous avons parlé des événements
attendons-nous maintenant aux acteurs de
la sainte politique certains peuvent se
taguer d'avoir pris de bonnes décisions
poser le bon geste d'autres peut-être dû
y réfléchir à deux fois voyons ce qui
mérite les applaudissements ou encore
les critiques chantales meilleure
performance
c'est vrai que sa campagne n'était pas
bonne mais François Legault quand même
est le premier ministre a remporté un
deuxième mandat consécutif depuis un
élément
ce qui est quand même une performance et
il dirige un parti qui avait jamais
gouverné il y a 4 ans 4 ans et demi et
son équipe ministérielle quand on la
regarde et qu'on accompagne à celle de
province comparable ce compare
avantageusement la plupart des conseils
des ministres dans les provinces
ailleurs au Canada d'ailleurs il y a
cette semaine angustrie qui publiait son
bulletin de fin d'année sur la côte
d'appréciation des premiers ministres
des provinces monsieur Legault en a
parlé lui-même
parce que non seulement il y a reçu des
fleurs mais il y a voulu les montrer à
tout le monde y arrive en tête c'est le
premier ministre que la plus forte cote
d'approbation Canada à 57%, 57% ne c'est
pas mal plus de monde que les gens qui
ont votaient pour la carte aux élections
votre meilleur performance
au sens strict Justin Trudeau devant la
commission rouleau c'est pas le genre
d'exercice où normalement il aurait
hybride il a été vraiment très bon en
plus on a pris plein d'affaires même les
gens qui suivent la politique de proches
on a appris comment se prennent des
décisions dans un dans une situation de
crise comme celle-là c'était intéressant
mais c'était dangereux pour lui et il le
fait la performance qu'il fallait je
pense alex je pense que vous êtes
d'accord là je l'avais sur ma courte
liste aussi très bonne performance de
Justin Trudeau moi j'ai choisi quelqu'un
qui n'est pas élu j'ai trouvé que la
performance de sophie Brochu son coup de
ce monde ça va la formation ce qu'on
conseille des ministres
menaces de démissionner
la fameuse électricité vendue à rabais
et la crainte qu'un ministre veuille
justement aller dans cette direction là
elle a quand même remporté le bras de
fer parce que il s'est créé un comité
première fois qui se crée un comité
arbitré par le Premier ministre ou un
non élu une non élu dans ce que si va si
la présidente d'Hydro-Québec pour
arbitrer les choix des projets qu'on va
faire où on s'en va dans quelle
direction ça prouve à quel point elle
emmène large on ne pouvait plus se
passer d'elle on a créé un comité pour
l'amadouer mais disons que son coup de
ce monde se raisonnait très fort c'était
politiquement risqué mais très habile
quand même du côté de sophie Brochu qui
s'est fait entendre et quand elle a
envoyé son sa petite note aux employés
d'Hydro-Québec le lendemain disant je
reste resté si ça c'était pas destiné à
être coulé et pour dire à tout le monde
j'étais bel et bien sérieuse dans mon
idée de quitter si ça faisait pas mon
affaire je sais pas ce que c'était mais
c'était très vite
des employés d'une société comme ça
c'est sûr
confiance ben voilà entre nous Michel Le
Maillon Faible des derniers six mois
le PQ lui-même qui a pas été à la
hauteur ni au plan de l'organisation ni
au plan de l'opposition qui doit mener à
Québec là il s'en va dans une course
dont on voit pas vraiment comment elle
va finir par se dérouler
c'était le parti naturel de gouvernement
son Québec c'est un grand parti dans
l'histoire du Québec et là c'est pas les
autres déjà dit tu participes québécois
c'est un chandrome je pense que là il
dirait vraiment la même chose du parti
ouais effectivement
je me suis mis à la place de Pierre
poillière aspirant Premier ministre
fédéral et je me suis dit ce serait quoi
mon plus gros problème dans la vie et là
ce serait pas juste intrudo parce qu'il
pense qu'il peut se battre ni François
Blanchet ou Jack meeting mais c'est
meilleur ami qui sont les premiers
ministres conservateurs des provinces on
a parlé tout à l'heure résistance
ne fera pas de photo de groupe avec
Monsieur polliève parce que elle est un
électeur antarien au prochain élections
fédérales que nos meilleurs amis c'est
Madame Smith en Alberta monsieur mot en
Saskatchewan qui ont des projets de loi
similaires sur la souveraineté à l'égard
du gouvernement fédéral de leur province
ou encore bliner
aux francophones au Québec est un ami un
Premier ministre qui veut mettre fin un
programme d'immersion dans sa province
qui est pas intéressé par le bilinguisme
de sa propre province ou encore dogford
qui
est revenu à son statut dans l'opinion
ontarienne d'avant la pandémie c'est à
dire dans le même bulletin des premiers
ministres monsieur Ford est rendu dans
le piloton de que avec à peu près 30%
d'appréciation c'est une grosse
dégringolade depuis des élections alors
tout le maillon faible en particulier du
mouvement conservateur qui veut
reprendre le pouvoir Ottawa ça va être
ses premiers ministre là et combien de
distance est-ce que Pierre poillière
peut maintenir surtout s'il commence va
dépendre des questions des médias il va
être obligé un jour de répondre à des
questions là-dessus aussi
je reviens sur la taxe Orange dont
parlait tout à l'heure
je sais pas c'est qui le maillon fait
parce que je sais pas qui a eu l'idée
mais je la donne parce que et pour pas
répéter ce que Michel le dit parce que
ça révèle un deuxième sujet un peu
délicat ou un peu tabou à Québec soldat
le premier étant 40 % des électeurs de
Québec solidaire sont fédéralistes on a
généralement pas trop en parler le
deuxième c'est Québec solidaire et
populaire chez la classe moyenne
supérieure pas chez les moins fortunés
pas chez la classe moyenne chez ceux qui
ont de l'argent en général et quand un
quartier se gentrifie que donc le
multiplexe dont parlait Michel dans
Rosemont finit par valoir un million
c'est le Québec solidaire et populaire
antique Rosemont Taschereau à Québec
maintenant Verdun et donc en touchant à
cette classe moyenne supérieure qui est
son électorat sans qu'il le disent
ouvertement cible ça fait du mal à un
parti pour peut-être plus qu'un cycle
électoral il faudra voir comment on
réussit à s'en sortir déjà on va
commencer à calibrer on ne dit que
c'était pas une super bonne idée on va
retravailler ça mais je trouve que c'est
révélateur d'avoir fait sortir peut-être
le deuxième tabou de Québec solidaire
c'est à dire que la classe moyenne
supérieure qui était favorable à Québec
offre un des deux pieds lorsque cette
politique est arrivée alors que chez les
partis politiques adverses on avait
Québec solidaire chez les francophones à
19 20 21 % dans les intentions de vote
au moment où François Legault commence à
taper chez sur la taxe orange je sais
pas pour rien on voyait Québec solidaire
monter ça s'est arrêté net complètement
ça a été abruptement est complètement
pris citron Chantal c'est pas pour une
fois quelqu'un qui est en politique j'ai
choisi la commissaire de la GRC Brandon
lockedin que la même date l'an prochain
on va parler au passé parce que son
mandat arrive à échéance en mars elle a
laissé savoir très maladroitement selon
moi qu'elle le voulait être renouvelé
j'ai l'impression que le gouvernement
est déjà à la recherche d'un successeur
pourquoi parce que son mandat était
particulièrement peu convaincant
problème de leadership problème de
gestion dans les événements qui sont
passés dans les Maritimes les fusillades
mais aussi
l'épisode à la commission ou l'eau où
elle explique qu'ils avaient finalement
un plan les forces policières un plan
coordonnées pour régler le problème sans
la Loi sur les mesures d'urgence elle
est invitée à la réunion du cabinet
et là on lui dit mais qu'est-ce que les
ministres ont dit quand vous leur avez
expliqué que vous aviez un plan et elle
a dit j'avais pas la parole alors je
leur ai pas dit
il y a quelqu'un qui va se faire peu
poliment lancer en dessous de l'autobus
à l'issue de cet exercice là je vous
dirai que c'est la première candidate ce
soir
ça sent bien votre savoir au mois de
février
il y a quelques choix quand même
j'ai toujours mon fameux
ministère de l'immigration
mais je suis allé avec Daniel Smith dont
on parlait tout à l'heure Chantal et sa
performance générale oui il y a eu la
loi sur la souveraineté de l'Alberta
dans un Canada uni qui a finalement un
dû être modifié je sais plus combien de
fois pour que ça passe la rampe mais ce
n'est pas sa seule gaffe elle en a fait
aussi tout de suite en arrivant disant
que les non vaccinés avaient été les
plus discriminés de l'histoire oubliant
quand même quelque part important de
notre société qui ont été discriminées
au fil du temps notamment les auto entre
autres dans sa propre province donc ça
montre quoi ça montre que le jugement
politique de daniosmitt n'est pas au
point malgré le fait qu'elle est déjà
été en politique qu'elle est une femme
qui vient des médias et que la campagne
électorale qui s'en vient même si c'est
une province conservatrice d'Alberta
pour être difficile pour elle si elle
multiplie ce type de gaffe là parce que
dans une campagne électorale tu peux pas
te reprendre trois ou quatre fois comme
elle le fait pour un projet de loi ça va
pas mal plus vite que ça surtout en
Alberto c'est des campagnes assez
courtes c'est très
courtes Michel
pour ce qui a fait après sa réélection
il y a réussi à se faire élire et là les
gars font commencer le projet de loi
utilisant la clause d'un habitant dans
des négociations avec ses employés bâtir
dans les zones vertes autour des grandes
villes antérieures je peux vous en avez
d'autres
elles sont refus d'aller devant la
commission rouleau aussi alors il est
vraiment passé de range à citron très
très rapidement ce monsieur là
c'est vrai le refus aéronise
toujours bien de finir sur une belle
note la révélation de l'année alecte la
vôtre
du destin avec le dépliant de Québec
solidaire mais je pense qu'il mérite
d'être à l'Assemblée nationale il a fait
une assez bonne campagne électorale deux
très bons débats et il attire il a tiré
l'attention tout l'automne avec un sujet
ma foi assez périphérique à la
préoccupation principale des gens
peut-être trop un peu mais en même temps
c'était habile d'un parti qui n'a que
trois députés donc je parle évidemment
du serment en roi là donc je pense que
waouh tout à fait c'est c'est les
piquets sont heureux de l'avoir c'est
déjà c'est déjà pas mal alors
non je pense qu'il mérite tout à fait
l'Assemblée nationale
je suis sorti complètement de la
politique puis même du Canada on en
parle pas souvent mais Bobby qui est
ambassadeur du Canada ou d'anciences
unis et vraiment se révèle être un super
ambassadeur qui reste en grande partie
la réputation du Canada qui donne enfin
un sens l'expression de Justin Trudeau à
son arrivée au pouvoir le Canada Espagne
le Canada est de retour il est pas
vraiment nécessairement de retour mais
aux Nations Unies certainement que c'est
dans la meilleure tradition
personneienne
le rôle qu'il joue j'ai comme
l'impression qu'il joue un assez grand
rôle aussi dans l'articulation de la
politique étrangère canadienne
actuellement je n'entends que de bonnes
choses à son sujet son travail
d'autant de travail je votre révélation
à vous
Bruno marchand le maire de Québec pour
avoir tenu tête au gouvernement selon le
troisième livre tout une campagne
électorale sans trop Salier descendants
avoir une nouvelle vision de la qualité
de vivre en ville
c'est
comme un peu l'ainé de cette nouvelle
génération de mer au Québec on dit tant
bien mais ça tombe bien parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui sait où il s'en va qui est
capable de
d'articuler les priorités des citoyens
dans sa politique
c'est quelqu'un de très intéressant et
je pense qu'on va attendre beaucoup
parler de lui une excellent choix
effectivement Michel après ce retour sur
les derniers mois d'actualité politique
allongé d'un coup d'oeil vers 2023 quel
dossier devrait être sur notre radar
qu'est-ce qui pourrait avoir un impact
important sur nos vies regarde vers
l'avenir c'est dans un moment à tout de
suite